it's been brought to my attention that
many of the comments videos an overall
tenor and tone of this program have been
considered hurtful and offensive to many
and while not in violation of policy
guidelines certainly started the line of
human decency I along with everyone here
at ladder with Crowder I'm not above
recognizing my mistakes and attempting
to rectify them so I'd like to take this
opportunity to formally apologize to all
parties involved firstly my heartfelt
apologies to practicing socialists
offended by the Che Guevera socialism is
for FIGS t-shirt I know that we should
fight bad ideas with good ideas and
respectfully debate the merits virtues
and shortcomings of socialism as opposed
to merely mocking it with a hysterical
t-shirt available at Lara's credit shop
calm also my apologies to the Nabisco
corporation and their Fig Newton
subsidiary I would also like to
apologize to Drake the rapper for
referring to him as a quote butter-soft
[ __ ] and claiming that his only
redeeming quality as a performer was
when he was shot into permanent
paralysis on Degrassi I'd also like to
apologize to Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
from plying that she's long been
deceased and even though I don't have
verifiable proof to the contrary I do
realize my observations were conducted
in poor taste and ill-timed I also
apologized for pant Ellis's remarks
implying that she looks like a cartoon
snail librarian to UFC heavyweight
champion Daniel Cormier I'm sorry for
describing your fighting style as that
of a quote hairless baby filled with
hate Daniel Cormier I'm sorry I'd also
like to retract my comment about
representative dan Crenshaw implying
that his mug shot would quote resemble
that of an angry pirate shift manager in
a Brooks Brothers catalog store and that
would be quote the stuff of children's
nightmares to my dear friend and
esteemed colleague Ben Shapiro I
sincerely apologize for implying that
you're a greedy shekel hoarder words
matter and while I swear I'm an greedy
in a good way I see now how it might
have been misconstrued Ben Shapiro I'm
sorry
while discussing my good friend and
esteemed colleague Ben I'd also like to
apologize for implying that his tumblers
spread cancer even though there's a
distinct possibility that they do spread
cancer the science has
to be conclusively settled and until it
is I should be more respectful the
number two drinking vessel and
conservatism I apologize also an apology
to the Jewish community at large for
wrongly pointing out that while they've
achieved great success in the realm of
medicine finance and technology God's
chosen people have yet to present a
viable athlete with a vertical jumping
capability greater than that of a
fourth-grade child
Jews were sorry also I apologise to the
Palestinian people for stating that they
were a quote backwards people from an
imaginary country that never really
existed because none of the Muslims
wanted you
Palestine I'm sorry I apologize to
General Motors for stating that their
cars were unreliable rattle boxes and
that I quote wouldn't drive a Chevy Volt
if I needed to get to the emergency room
and my dick was on fire
GM I'm sorry apologies to the Sicilian
community for in poor taste stating that
while they were technically Italian if
they examine their family tree closely
enough there was a strong likelihood
that they quote find a black man hiding
behind their woodshed somewhere I'd like
to issue an apology to Tess holiday for
incorrectly implying that her blood type
was biologically comparable to that of
pudding she's both brave and beautiful
and I should have done more to celebrate
that also an apology to the jell-o
pudding corporation for associating
their product with Tess Holliday finally
apologies to aquatic mammals for
comparing them to test holiday as well
speaking of our aquatic mammalian
community I would like to apologize to
Amy Schumer whom I've implied to be
grossly overweight dangerously
promiscuous and reprehensibly unfunny we
should remember her when she was at her
best at a point where she was funny I'd
like to formally apologize to Vice
President Joe Biden for stating that he
is quote the kind of guy who would have
his bachelor party hosted at a Chuckie
Cheese I would also like to apologize
for a poorly timed and distasteful Biden
grab-ass spongebob cartoon parody also
apologies to Nick at night to my
half-asian lawyer bill Richman I would
like to apologize for the insinuation
that his billable hours exceed those
actually worked as well as accusing him
of covering hopper and dry rub in
preparation for Mongolian fusion
barbeque half-asian bill I'm sorry I'd
like to ask for forgiveness from the
hodgetwins for comparing them to quote
the Kriss Kross guys all grown up on
anavar my deepest apologies to Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau for
comparing him to a glistening vagina
even when we disagree we should be more
mindful of our world leaders and the
great burden they carry on their lips
also I apologise to vaginas everywhere
for comparing them wrongfully to Justin
Trudeau vaginas serve a viable useful
and pleasant purpose seeing as I do not
have one I now understand that I am not
entitled to an opinion on their goings
on finally I would like to apologize to
the city of Quebec for this mustache I'm
sorry to Dave Rubin for in sensitively
pointing out that he is quote the most
boring domesticated gay man since Rock
Hudson played doctor with Gomer Pyle and
to my employee colleague and my dear
friend Brautigan
I apologize for insinuating that even
though I would love him just the same
his uncomfortable enthusiasm for both
Taylor Swift and the pitch-perfect
franchise led me to believe that he was
a blatant practicing homosexual or at
the very least a little bi rot again I'm
sorry I'd like to formally apologize to
the Bob Ross estate for tarnishing his
legacy with a portrayal of Muhammad's
likeness subsequently painting in period
blood and finally painting his legal
team is eating from a corn infest and
pile of fecal matter alongside the
holiest of prophets Muhammad peace be
upon him I apologize to the drag queen
story time for trampling on what was
solely intended to be an educational and
family-friendly experience at the
Houston public library with sex
offenders I'd like to take a moment to
apologize to Planned Parenthood for
quitting their sales tactics with that
of a used car salesman with our
installments crazy Pete's abortion barn
both one and two
along with crazy Pete's embryonic stem
cell Emporium I'd also like to apologize
to used-car salesmen everywhere who work
hard and form the backbone of this
society's working class and they did
nothing to invite this unwarranted
comparison also a second apology to
Planned Parenthood is in order for
deceiving them into the false notion
that Stefan
Crowder was indeed a real pregnant trans
woman I would also like to apologize to
the woman who's pregnant urine was used
in said video
illicitly obtained on a Craigslist
advertisement and not being forthright
with the urines intended purpose
speaking of Stephanie I'd like to
formally apologize to state senator
Wendy Davis for deceiving her into
believing that Stephanie was an actual
transgender woman attending the Austin
women's March miss Davis had a promising
political career before being
interviewed by Stephanie and I regret
the subsequent de railing as a result of
such a convincing portrayal I'd also
like to take this chance to make amends
with Planet Fitness I'm sorry that you
two were convinced by my dishonest
portrayal and for setting off your lung
kalam no less than 18 times I'd like to
apologize to Lena Dunham for the
constant comparisons for the constant
comparisons to her physical appearance
in that of Shamu I have since retro
actively directed all of my staff to
remove all pictures of Lena Dunham in
their entirety from our archives to
Bruce Lee and his fans I would like to
apologize for insinuating that Bruce Lee
was an overrated hundred and thirty-five
pound weakling bereft of any fighting
ability with no actual combat record
whatsoever Bruce and fans I apologize my
regrets and apologies are expressed to
quarterblack Garrett for needlessly
insisting that his racial ambiguity act
as a focal point in this programming
quarterblack Garrett works tirelessly
both behind and in front of the cameras
and his lifelong inability to find
acceptance among the black or white
communities of America is far more
painful than any mockery I could serve
him as punishment I understand that now
I'm sorry my apologies to the Motor City
Madman Ted Nugent for my statement that
his skin resembles and smells like that
of bison jerky was originally intended
as a compliment I'd like to clarify but
I now understand why he might have taken
offense I'd also like to apologize to
our esteemed president Donald Trump for
my ill-timed Trump talk series of videos
one of which I as president Trump
implied that megyn kelly was a [ __ ] I
now understand that I was far out of
line and we'll leave said methods of
attacked with our president in the
future
I'm sorry mouth megyn n president Trump
also apologies to former Secretary
Terry of State Hillary Clinton for
implying that she couldn't stand her own
two feet that she coughed up a lung on
more than one occasion for stating that
she covered up her husband's alleged
rapes and for circulating both
mean-spirited and unconfirmed rumors
that she was both Houmas lover and a
practicing witch like to issue a formal
apology to dr. Christine Blasi Ford for
not giving her her earned title the
respect that it deserves instead simply
calling her Christie and I apologize for
insinuating that the investigative
parties had left her case open to the
distinct possibility of her being a
quote lying [ __ ] dr. Christie I'm sorry
I'd also like to issue an apology to the
fine people of Great Britain for
perpetuating the hurtful stereotype that
the British people are incapable of
basic dental hygiene my deepest
apologies to Alexandria Castillo Cortes
for the callous aoc deep thoughts sketch
which equates a OC with a bug-eyed
cartoon too stupid to form cogent
thoughts and may perhaps suffer from a
form of early onset dementia which I now
know is no laughing matter ever and I
apologize to Marvel Comics I would like
to apologize for my statement that your
catalogue of crappy films was surpassed
only by your casting of social justice
warrior [ __ ] for calling your
standout star infinity twink and to DC
Comics I'd like to apologize for saying
that you wish you were Marvel I'd like
to issue an apology to Bernie Sanders
for not only mocking his socialist and
authoritarian viewpoints without mercy
but also for my own accurate portrayals
of him including but not limited to
Gilbert Godfrey Bernie dr. Jekyll Bernie
rush and commie Bernie professional
stripper Bernie and all other Bernie
incarnations therein I'd like to
apologize to the always stunning and
brave Caitlyn Jenner for misgendering
her and implying that she is not a real
woman also for insinuating with her
downstairs resembles that of a crab
rangoon also I sincerely apologize for
mocking the women's March as quote just
another excuse for HR to take a day off
work my deepest regrets to the Yorkshire
Terriers and the Yorkie enthusiast
community for implying that they are not
real dogs and quote make good soup also
I apologise again to the Asian community
for insisting that many of them eat dogs
I should be more mindful and tolerant
others culture and culinary customs
sorry - bret baier Francey doing that
his hairs hairline was so low that i
couldn't quote tell where his eyebrows
ended and forehead begins i apologize to
noted hip-hop star MC bulletproof for
within 24 hours of his untimely death
stating in jest that quote apparently
god's sided with his notorious rival MC
armor-piercing bullets and now see that
it was both heal timed and performed in
poor taste I'm sorry to my good friend
Andrew Clavin for my statements
regarding my requirement in wearing
quote solar eclipse glasses just to look
in the general direction of his gleaming
bald skull and subsequently following it
up with the implication that quote he
would make a great Captain America
villain in 2014 a joke appeared in this
program which was written as follows if
an angry feminist is raped in a forest
with no one near to here is she still
heinous ly unattractive I'd like to
apologize for that joke to the victims
of sexual assault as well as the
Japanese people and vibrant culture of
the haikyuu community for both our
appropriation and our insensitivity I'd
also like to apologize to BuzzFeed for
saying that they were staffed by quote
failed English majors with multiple
pokemon tattoos that belong to a secret
buzz cut at lesbian motorcycle chain
gang buzz feet I'm sorry I'd also like
to say that I'm sorry to brian Stelter
for implying that he resembled a Barney
from The Simpsons if he were on an
episode of queer I also for a writer pen
tells his observation that quote for a
talking penis he lacks charisma
apologies to John Kasich for describing
him as an annoying wiener and the kind
of guy who would show up uninvited to a
party with a warm case of Zima as well
as implying that his hair quote
resembled that of a newly birthed baby
bird in a BP oil spill
sticking with the 2016 primary an
apology to Carly Fiorina for in our
cartoon debate allowing john Kasich's
character to imply that her womb was
barren i need to issue an apology
I now realize this was offensive to the
bear and wound community and that miss
Fiorina is of course not amongst them
also - dr. ben Carson I have apologized
for implying that he quote sound
like a Jim Henson character who required
the game be turned up on his log of the
Lear microphone I also apologized to
Senator Rand Paul for comparing his
haircut to quote those little bristles
on a toilet brush in our company
greenroom restroom Senator Rand Paul I'm
sorry I humbly apologize to feminist
scholar Naomi wolf for insinuating that
a true frog did it I apologize to
feminist scholar Naomi Wolf she deserves
the right apology for insinuating that a
true strong feminist would when
appearing on a national broadcast quote
at least have the foresight to charge
her phone apologies to the uncircumcised
community at large for implying that
their members look like a quote Chinese
finger trap or one of those quote toys
silicon bags you would buy at the local
Dollar Tree which constantly slips out
of your hands to Johnny Mathis
I apologize for stating that while he is
immensely talented that due to his
setting of high school record track
meets he was quote the worst kind of
queer because you could never outrun him
I apologized to Don Lemon as well for
implying that he looks like a dead
Johnny Mathis and is aging faster than a
paddling from the Dark Crystal I
apologize to the Young Turks for the
following Ana Kasparian for showing both
the before and after picture of your
rhinoplasty surgery and for calling you
a brace traitor for sitting alongside in
Armenian Genocide and I are all these
years to the homosexual buzz Quetta
gentlemen I apologize for never having
learned your proper name I also like I
would also like to apologize to chanc
Weger for crashing his
south-by-southwest panel as chanc Weger
to the immigrant community I would like
to apologize for the implication that
illegally entering this country is a
recognized crime by definition making
one a criminal I would also like to
apologize to the Latin Kings ms-13 as
well as the Bloods and the Crips for
insisting that they were violent gangs
and closeted homosexuals when in fact
they have served as protectors and
pillars of their community for decades
past and hopefully yet to come I'd like
to issue an apology to Tom Jones for
sitting it on his early television
program his pants were so tight that it
quote looked like he was attempting to
smuggle a deformed
energetic mushroom I apologize to the
Hells Angels for claiming that I quote
couldn't pick them out from a lineup
full of Folsom street fights to Jessi
Smollett for our segment of what a piece
of Jessi Smollett edition which now is
hovering over 1.9 million views I hope
it never hits 2 million the link is in
the description mr. Smollett I'm sorry I
apologize to Nathan Phillips for
implying that he looked like a toothless
meth head and denigrating the rich
Native American tradition of
self-discovery by referring to it as a
quote methamphetamine quest I also
apologized to the good people of Harley
Davidson for referring to their bikes as
quote overpriced penis compensation
devices that spend more time in the
garage and they ever do between the legs
of the closeted cher fan who was stupid
enough to purchase it harley purchasers
and riders I'm sorry I would also like
to apologize to Bill O'Reilly for
including him and no less than 21
photoshop's was either directly affirmed
or indirectly insinuated the now known
to be completely baseless allegations of
a sexual misconduct and to Eric Bolling
I apologize for including him and no
less than 14 have said photoshop's
insinuating him as an accomplice when
asked to remove these photo shops I'd
like to apologize for hastily and lazily
pasting over the clear Eric Bolling
photograph with Kevin Spacey's face
while subsequently including his images
hidden easter eggs for photo shops in
the months to come I apologize to the
people of Detroit for denigrating the
city's policies architecture
infrastructure citizens and culture with
relentless regularity and vigor not only
going so far as to shoot multiple videos
there but even going so far as to
campaign for them to be annexed to
Canada and relieve America of the
greatest metropolitan stain in our
nation's history I would also like to
apologize to the country of Canada for
subsequently and actively lobbying that
we bomb them or is never something of
which we should make light also
apologies to the Canadian military for
implying that their Air Force consisted
of quote nothing more than a single
propeller Blaine with a 22 rifle and
belittling the great contributions made
delivering the world of tyranny through
their notable peacekeeping sir
I apologize to the country of India in
its entirety for keeping up forever you
lie on it in the streets should not be a
litmus test of whether your country is
to be considered among the developed
world while on the subject I'd like to
apologize to California for the same
reason I apologize to the gay community
for pointing out making jokes regarding
the statistics that reflect aids as
being virtually an entirely homosexual
disease in the modern world in failing
to point out the additional single-digit
contribution rate from recycled
hypodermic needle users I did a great
disservice to our audience in robbing
them of accurate and potentially helpful
reporting I apologize to YouTube CEO
Susan Wojcicki I'm I'm sorry for not
only wrongly implying her to be a
leftist authoritarian but for
unflattering portrayals of her as
performed by quarterblack Garrett max
missed the PA and none other than Clint
Howard I'd like to apologize to Paul
Joseph Watson for stating that he quote
looked like the high school bully in an
early 90s teen film also to Sean Hannity
for implying that he looks like Fred
Flintstone incarnate and has a Fripp has
a head like a refrigerator and - Matt
Iseman for making fun of his favorite
band Creed like to apologize to Harvey
Weinstein for stating that he has an
unhealthy attraction to ficus plants
which was a terrible and poorly way
poorly worded way to speak of Jennifer
Lawrence I'd like to apologize to Glenn
Beck for sitting that his bit where he
stuck his face and the Cheetos was quote
as funny as testicular cancer I'd like
to apologize to both the burrowing owl
and its conservation community there in
who have suffered needlessly from my
tireless assault on this animal which
has led to both its increased capture
and placement on the endangered species
list I should have never referred to the
burrowing owl as quote an abomination
that natural selection would have
eliminated if not for useless patchouli
wearing Birkenstocks lesbian activists
with too much time on their hands I'd
like to apologize to a majority of the
world's Islamic fundamentalists for the
apt but poorly worded comparison and
that they were quote pretty much just
Nazis who beat their wives I would like
to apologize to both the National work
nationalist work
I would like to apologize to both the
nationalist Socialist Workers Party of
Germany as well as the organisation of
breastfeeding mothers of Germany for my
unflattering and historically inaccurate
portrayal of [ __ ] breastfeeding Adolf
Hitler well that was not my intended
goal I now realize that my portrayal has
led only to the increased stigmatization
of public breastfeeding as well as the
Nazi Party finally I would like to
apologize for the use of all of the
following racially sexually and
generally prettily charged pejorative
nouns and/or ejectives that have been
used on this program homo coloured queer
to Rear Admiral buzz cut at lesbian
chain gang kind of chip starfish and
Mexican I think I think that about
covers it again I would like to issue my
sincerest apologies and if I forgotten
anybody please list your grievances in
the comments below I'll be sure to get
back to you with great haste thank you